Daniel: Well.
To talk a little about
what Juan talked about
I think the best comparison
"is the one between, for example,"
a TV network and a movie studio.
Social games are
the new TV channels;
they are the new soap operas.
"So, for example,"
"you have to change the contents every day,"
every new episode.
"So, you have to be more..."
"you have to change the app, the game."
It's very different from the movie industry
where you do a project for a long time;
you launch a project and
later don't change it.
"They both have very large audiences,"
but you have to change
social games.
"The hardest part is after the launch,"
not before.
That's a big difference.
He also talked about distribution.
Games have wide distribution.
Monetization is different.
"For example, in traditional games"
you have to use a console.
"you have to pay each month,"
something like that.
Social games are free.
"Generally, there's a premium model"
that some users will pay.
But day-to-day
rather than long-term.
Eduardo: I want to hear a little bit more
about what you said there
that keeping up with a game
is more work than launching it.
"What are some of the bigger challenges,"
as much for getting it online
"in its conception,"
"as to put it on the air, and then"
to keep it on the air?
What are the main points
that need attention?
Daneil: Well.
"Eduardo: Let's go from there to here, now."
Daniel: Yes.
"Well, I was talking about"
"distribution,"
viralization of the game is the most difficult.
"For example, you have to choose "
"a platform that you can distribuite,"
[inaudible] is a good example of this.
But to create a game where the users
"are going to share it with friends,"
knowing the mechanisms that will let
the game be distributed is really important.
Lots of time we [inaudible] the market
"good games, but games that don't "
have the social part well defined.
They don't have the viralization that
allows millions of gamers to share them.
That's one thing.
The second thing that is difficult for
social games is customizing the content.
One thing that we here at Voso
do a lot is
"customize the content, not only"
"well, the mathematics of the game,"
but also the style of the game
that the users are going to respond
to the needs of users.
"Social games,"
you have a lot of information about the
"users, and the information"
"will change each day, so you have to "
respond to the users' needs.
There's not a lot of time
to respond.
"If you take too much time,"
the users will leave for the next game.
So these are the real challenges.
"Beyond this, there's also"
the challenge of monetization;
You have to be really aggressive
to find the most important ways
that the user will want
to buy credits within the game.
I think that's another important challenge.
Bruno: The biggest challenge I see
is the scalability of the app.
We've got a very interesting case
in the soccer apps [...Corintians...]
one week it had close to
"a million fans, added users"
and in a month it was up to
two million.
So for something to grow
that quickly
I think that's a big challenge
for those who aren't used to...
"who want to launch a game,"
the costs are...
in how things are going to work inside it.
But if it doesn't have a good background
it won't work out.
Juan: A summary of what Daniel
"and Bruno talked about,"
I think that there are
two main goals.
"One is scalability, technically"
different from games...
social games grow very quickly.
If you have a successful app
it's going to grow quickly.
The architecture of your game
has to be ready for the growth.
An example: we worked on [A colheita feliz]
"a very popular game in Brazil,"
"it went fomr 10,000 users to 20 million"
active users in less than a month.
So it's very difficult to be ready
for that.
And a daily goal is the
server achitecture
and the game architecture.
"So, when you are thinking "
"about a social game,"
"of a successful game,"
from the beginning you have to create
a game architecture
that allows scaling.
"Not only the physical part, the servers, "
but also the software.
And the other part that Daniel talked
about was the monetization.
Social games are free.
We make money when people
pay for premium content.
And for those who pay for
premium content
you need local content
and content every day.
"So to make a game,"
to develop a game is the first part
but you need to make new items
every day
"dogs, balloons, flags"
depending on the game
so that people become involved
"in the game,"
they spend money on the game.
"So, I think it's an opportunity"
there are few barriers to entry
you can be developing
not only for Brazil
but for the whole world.
But you always have to think about
the scalability of the game.
and the structure to monetize the game.
Eduardo: Cool.
"A few times, Daniel quoted a term"
that's in vogue
and that's viralization.
And I've seen that all of your apps
some very intelligent strategies
and very creative strategies about how
to make this viralization work.
Can you talk a little about this
some examples of cases in which
changing the game suddenly
"it was clearly more viral, it"
the growth changed a lot?
What type of change was the most relevant?
Juan: To make a game
you have...
something important is the social platform.
Social games are in social networks.
And social networks have
social architectures.
The idea is that you maximize
the social platforms
so that the game goes viral.
This is the first thing
the most basic thing.
"Afterwards, to the degree that the users"
play a series of activities
that you can post
"on social networks,"
on Twitter
Not only on social networks
but there are other social channels.
There are important things
when you have other games
or various games
that you can begin to create
user engagement
so that the user begins
to migrate to new games
begins to migrate with his friends
to your new games.
[inaudible] interesting things
is the social activity within a game
so that the game is interesting
and the user has to play
but has to share the game
with his friends;
and has to invite his friends to play.
he has to test his friends;
to collaborate with his friends.
All of these architectures are what
"make the game more social,"
more viral or less viral.
Bruno: In our case...
we have a very interesting case
that was with the apps [dosul]
We noticed that it got
stretched a little...
after changing Orkut
it allowed
before it allowed up to three open apps
"in profile view, and later"
"it allowed only one,"
we were feeling down.
We were so upset there in
[inaudible] showed and all to improve this.
"Above all, he spoke about maximizing the use"
"that's what it is, you know, if you "
understood where you're dealing with
or what it is that becomes possible
and use the most you can.
I think the best thing to use viralization
are the activities there...
that you follow the user's stream
like it was a Twitter feed.
And we had some interesting work
in that
to keep up the quantitiy
of additional users and such.
The apps...
there are apps
"that aren't games,"
they have a little different profile
"than the games, right?"
Games today --
if you were to compare the
number of addtional users
some apps like [A Minha M˙sica] that
"have 9 million manage to easily reach,"
but uses during the week are
much less than the games.
"So, what we tried to do"
is some work on top of that
to try to even out the ranking
and keep on having
cool work against the games
Daniel: I think it's also important
"for example, within Orkut,"
to exploit the updates and know that
when a person enters the game
"the app has to invite his friends,"
"too, to play the game."
"So [inaudible] of the examples,"
"for example, in Mini Fazenda,"
one of our games
the users can create
"a Halloween mansion, now."
So the users have to ask
their friends for materials
and collect materials from their friends.
So they viralize the game
through Orkut's resources.
"And have a list, collect."
"In another game, for example, "
"[Crack] or [Boustu] Poker, you have to"
"to compete,"
a strong incentive for users
to viralize the game.
So in Espacio Desafio
they're going to talk to their friends
so that they can win the challenge.
So using the tools that
Orkut gives you...
"and also avenues like email,"
is very important.
But each game has to follow
all of these avenues.
And you can really reach the users.
I think the mechanics are the most important.
If you don't have the mechanisms
"for viralization in all parts of the game,"
"the app,"
it's really hard to make the users
come back to the game.
Eduardo: I'm a real-live example of that.
I have a lot of...
from cousins to friends...
"that work at Orkut,"
so they go there and [inaudible]
so if they're needing some help
to finish building the farm. You
don't spend the whole day
surfing Orkut...
"Help me, man!"
The call to...
social I think is a very interesting
piece of the app.
Let me change topics a bit.
How much work is involved in...
in the creation as well as
in the upkeep of the app?
Both from the perspecitve of the number
"of people, as well as the their profiles?"
I know there are several different kinds
"of people involved, from infrastructure"
to content creation.
Talk a little more
about this.
Daniel: Good.
Generally we have studio models.
"So, for example, to create a game"
a 4 or 6 month process
a good game
"there are more or less 30, 40 people."
And... well...
"there are testing people,"
"people for art and design, and..."
"technical, there's Java, Flash"
building the front end.
"And, well, that's just to create"
a game.
Once a game is launched
that same team has to do
the maintenance for the game.
"So, for example,"
one of our games has
"Mini Fazenda, in assets"
this game alone has
"20,000 transactions per second."
At the peak
"40,000 transactions per second"
in the database layer.
So you need an infrastructure team
a payment team
"support, complaints..."
they didn't get their tokens...
or the cow isn't moving...
something like that.
So that kind of support is a very
important part of the community.
So once the game is launched
you need the same team
"the people won't change,"
but will grow.
So the Mini Fazenda team began with
10 people and now there are almost 50.
It's a long-range process
depending on the quality of the game.
But I think that for apps
you don't need that many people.
But it is important to have a good team
and what we also learned in the process
is that it's important to have
for example
testing people close to the
art and design people
because they have a different perspective
and one person will add in
a cow to Mini Fazenda
"and it's wrong, and the design people"
will tell them.
So it's a much faster movement
inside the process of
development when you have
complementary people working together.
I think that it's also important...
In case you're thinking about
"creating an app, a game"
look for help from people who
complement what you know.
Bruno: Great.
What he spoke about
teams working together...
At [inaudible] we work with
a development team
"as much with development as layout,"
"planning, more or less horizontal"
So everyone is in the middle of everything
and we try to involve
the interested parties as much as possible.
Whoever likes soccer
is on top of everything;
in order to colaborate
as much as possible.
"Now, about the team"
when we think... have ideas
say something
[inaudible] everyone gets together
with everything they think is interesting
"there's planning, design"
programming;
and they do the planning and everything
from there there's the art team
there's a separate programming team
and
and we [inaudible] not the sound
today there aren't more than 6 people
"involved, one person who's in charge of"
soccer and who knows everything.
"And there's upkeep, just like he said."
It's not easy to maintain
because of what
he said about the number
of users and such.
So it's not just that there's one layer
it's not like simple programming
you have to be
everything has to be optimized.
You're not going to make direct requests
to the database all the time;
"you're going to use the same cache,"
"you're going to use recalls,"
you're going to use a lot of technology
so you don't go to the database because
of its size and increase the delay
reduce the delay due to
requests and everything.
The people keep on eating it up.
Juan: I think the main challenge
of this market is time-to-market.
It's a fast-paced market.
And if you don't get things
to market quickly
get to market first
second to market
you're out of the market...
in the gaming field.
"People, the users arent' going to play"
the third Fazenda.
"They played A Colheita,"
they played another
they're not going to play any more
they're going to look for a new game.
So time-to-market is very important.
Another thing is what Daniel talked about
It's complex to make
an successful social game.
and each day it's more complex
because the users
we and other developers
are educating the user
and producing games that are
more complex every day.
"So, for you to be successful"
you have to go to the next level.
"So, there's an interesting opportunity"
that we create.
We are not the developer.
We're the publisher.
"So, we work with developers"
like you
"in Brazil, in China, in California"
and we facilitate
your development.
"But, like us, there are people"
who are publishers
"in Russia, in China, in the U.S."
"So it's an interesting market, yes."
"It's a market with a lot of challenges, yes."
"It's a fast-paced market, yes."
The product cycle
"product life cycles are short, yes."
but there's an opportunity.
So I think you should begin to look for
ways to leverage your development
[eskids]
to have an impact on the Brazillian
market and outside of Brazil.
I think it's a good opportunity for you.
Eduardo: Cool.
"Daniel, I mentioned the strategy  "
for monetization a little bit.
I don't know if you're clear about
this term.
I have the impression that it's a very
Google term.
Monetization is how
you make money.
So I wanted you to talk a little
about this.
How can you make money
doing what we like to do
developing cool apps?
Because the simple use by the user
"the numbers are cool, they've surpassed"
"a million people, suddenly"
a lot of costs are generated.
It's important that you have opportunites
to convert them into receipts.
I wanted to hear a little from you
as much about the ideas that worked
"and, including"
the ideas that you
may have tried
but may not have been
well executed.
Juan: Monetization is very important.
"If we, if you don't make money"
you aren't going to be able to continue
in this market
you're not going to be able to invest and
create interesting studios in the future.
So monetization is very important.
Monetization of these games has changed
a lot and is evolving a lot.
"In the beginning, the people with"
monetziation [inaudible]
after monetization campaigns with [inaudible]
and now we are in microtransactions
(microtransactions)
And when you release premium content
to the user
"the user wants a red dog,"
they buy a red dog.
I think there are two things important
for monetization.
"Content every day, interesting content"
relevant to the user
and content every day
I think being smart about the business.
Measurement is very important.
You have to measure each second.
"If you release new content,"
within the next 20-30 minutes
you have to evaluate the impact
of that new content based on the users.
Because this is a fast-paced market
it's day-to-day.
So measuring user behavior
on top of the monetization related
to the content you're developing
is very interesting and important.
Bruno: With monetization strategy
we have not yet used this
something like Jambool
that type of monetization.
Our monetization
for now is [Banner].
But I see out there
"that could work, for example,"
today there's a lot in little games [Cash]
that you pay through PayPal
[mobile] you make a little money.
"And I, then, there's a game that"
"isn't part of my case,"
"for example, a great case"
is the one of [Bis]
[Bis] made the app.
So what happens is
we have
we were talking about
it's a good business that
"let's us put something, for example,"
"into a social game,"
"for example, in Colheita Feliz,"
you can buy two things
two types of things...
one functional item you can use
something different
you'll get an experience
or something like that
or some kind of decoration
you can put on.
And where I see potential
for apps expression in general
"like soccer, for example,"
somebody could be paying
to have a different wallet
or something like that.
Daniel: Good.
I think it's interesting
what Bruno said
about payment options.
I think that for games
for social games
you have to give the users
a lot of payment options.
"In our games, we take"
"cash, SMS, PayPal, credit card."
You can go to a LandHouse and pay for
a range of payment methods.
"This is really important in this market,"
particularly because a lot of users
are young;
they don't have credit cards.
So to be able to monetize
you need to give options.
That's one part of monetization.
Another part is what Juan talked a little
about: data mining.
So for example when we launched
a juice machine on CafÈ Mania
we do tests
we check the launch at midnight
and we make tests with 3 prices.
"5% of the users get one price,"
"5% another price,"
and 5% another price.
The price that gets the best...
the largest demand is launched
to the rest of the users.
And for the rest it was discounted.
So the idea of making tests
with social games
to better understand monetization
is really important to users.
So you have to
"give payment options,"
and at the same time know
what prices users can pay
And that way raise the percentage
of the users who pay
and also raise how much
each user pays.
Those are two ways to think about
monetization.
Eduardo: Really cool.
"In short, I want to open up so that "
you can also ask questions.
I don't want to monopolize the microphone.
"Before that, I'd like to"
ask just one question...
What do you see as
the future of this market?
Want are the next steps?
Where is the market going
"not only for apps,"
but also for social games?
Daniel: Well.
The market begins
I think we still have a lot to do
in the market.
The market will grow a lot.
"For example, in the most developed"
"market, in my opinion, Japan,"
"all social gaming,"
"all mobile,"
they've got the fever for social games.
I think that's more or less what
will happen in the future.
"I don't know if it'll be mobile in Brazil,"
"or if it will be other platforms,"
but it's really important to consider
multiplatforms.
"Android, really interesting..."
Orkut will continue to grow and be important...
to follow the users
wherever they are now.
"And also consider other games,"
"other types of games,"
other ways users interact.
So I think this is just the beginning.
Bruno: I think the future is also in the
decentralization of the social network itself.
A guy consumes...
comes to consume the same game
that he consumes with the same
data on the social network.
"on mobile, or on whatever network."
I think that's it.
Juan: I agree a lot
with what they said.
It's difficult.
The market is growing.
I think it's a big opportunity.
It'll keep on growing.
I also think the future is
in multiplatform integration.
Not only multiplatforms
"for social networks,"
but multiplatforms for mobile
or outside social [inaudible]
But the idea is that the user experience
"if it's on Orkut,"
or if on mobile
or on Facebook
and he's playing the same game
that the user experience be the same
and the information be the same;
that all the user's activity
on Orkut when he plays mobile
has activity there.
And that all the actions that he makes
with mobile will be affected
on Orkut or in other social [countries].
"So I think it's a big opportunity,"
but in the future it's more about
"games that are increasingly complex,"
and multiplatform integration.
Eduardo: Cool.
I want to switch to your side now.
There are two microphones in the back
if you could turn on the lights.
Thank you.
So anyone who wants
"to ask a question,"
please raise your hand.
"Sorry, please introduce yourself"
before asking your question.
>> My name is Eliane.
I'm the project director for a
digital agency called [redPepper].
One thing that worries us a lot when
we go to develop something...
[even] more is that the access speed
"is so high,"
the number of users...
how are you going to deal with
"for example, with a data center,"
"where do you begin,"
"""Look, we're thinking about"
"making a game,"""
and suddenly you have
20 million accessing the game.
"That's something I'd like to know,"
how do you handle that matter?
The subject of infrastructure.
How do you...
how do businesses
negotiate some of this?
Because what happens a lot is that
you start to be successful
and then you get a much higher
charge that you have to pay.
Much larger than you ever planned.
Juan: Bruno...
"Burno: In our case, specifically [Sutsol]"
we've partnered with Terra
so we have 10 desktops
at the telephone data center
that we can use
the way we best understand.
So we have a good option
that we saw there today
so that you can make the web engine
or some scale change by yourself
to make it easier to take care of the
growth without a lot of trouble
I imagine.
>> And was that good for you?
Did it work out?
Was it ever a lot of trouble?
I mean...
Weren't you charged extra because
of the fact you were there?
Bruno: We were.
From the beginning.
But then it's a question of optimization.
We managed to keep...
"When we launched A Minha M˙sica,"
"as much as the soccer apps,"
we didn't expect
to score a goal.
"And so, we didn't really have to..."
we didn't expect it to turn out
one way or the other.
So this planning is tough work
"structuring the database,"
dealing with requests
is getting less.
"And as a result, today we use"
"a lot less access,"
we use less...
fewer resources than we did
at the time of the launch.
>> It was very fast...
Thanks.
Eduardo: Anyone else?
Hi. I'm Daniel.
I'm the technology manager at CIT.
[inaudible] add to the last question a bit.
I want to know if you have ever seriously
evaluated some of the cloud structures
that are available today on the market
for you to be able to migrate...
or be interested in migrating...
the current processing structure
from your server side
to one of the cloud architectures
"available on the market, like"
"for example, App Engine."
"Bruno: In my case, no,"
because we have a partnership;
so we don't pay for transfers
"and such, it's for free."
So we don't have to worry
about that kind of thing.
"Daniel: Well, OK."
"Today for example,"
we manage about
a petabyte of data each month.
Two months ago it was a third of that.
"So with that kind of growth, what we"
"try to do with new games,"
"and I think it's a good idea for you,"
is to start with Amazon.
I think Amazon is a good option for a
game whose growth you don't know.
What we do next is once traffic
"is stabilized in a game,"
"a month after being launched,"
we change or make a transfer
to our data center.
We have a data center.
So I [am] in the United States
but I think that
this system is good for us.
Amazon helps with scaling
"so that, OK,"
in the beginning we don't know if the game
"will have 10 million users in the 1st month,"
or 15 million in the first month...
It's possible to add
more and more support later
once the traffic is stable
you can move to the data center
or look for more economical options.
Juan: We also work with Amazon.
We have data centers with work with.
The virtual cloud computing part
with Amazon
And the physical servers with...
with another...
with another data center in the U.S.
And we use a similar approach.
Initially we always struggled with Amazon
Amazon's scalability is very good
and the cost of the partnership
we have with them is...
isn't very high.
The cost in the U.S. is
a lot less than in Brazil;
data centers in Brazil
are still very expensive.
We all work with them there.
"And when a game needs, and the"
"virtual part requires, more capacity"
we move things to a data center
where we have physical servers.
But I think that the scalability
is not only based on the
data center and hardware.
Scalability is very important in the
software and architecture of the game.
So don't ever forget that.
"When you need to scale up,"
if the architecture isn't ready
the problem can't be resolved
by physical means.
>> Hi. My name is Welington.
"I'm the media director, Orkut digital agency."
I want to know if...
this idea of viralization of the game.
When you have some
users within a social game
the actual mechanics like you talked about
facilitate the viralization and people play
for the social dynamics themselves.
I want to know if you have any strategies
to make that begin to happen.
The first users.
Because nobody plays
a social game alone.
"So, how do you make the first users"
begin to hand over the game
to their friends and then
the thing grows exponentially.
and the game starts with [inaudible]
How do you attract the first users?
How do you start it?
Daniel: Well.
Speaking a little about
what I said earlier.
When users come into the game
"for the first time,"
it's important for them to know
that inviting their friends
is important to the game.
The game experience will be better
if you invite your friends.
"So, for example,"
in the first session of our games
users invite their friends
and get a bonus if they do that.
"For example,"
"there are updates within Orkut,"
"so if you do something,"
"an activitiy in the game,"
it will launch the update.
So their friends will know
that you are playing that game.
But I think it's important that
in the first experience with the game
for the users not to depend a lot
"on the social part,"
give a lot of interaction so that
they come to know the game a little
and there's a good tutorial and so on.
"Later, he'll invite others."
"At Orkut, for example,"
"in the first games,"
the Orkut communities were
fantastic in inviting friends.
"Users came to the community,"
talked about the game.
Later there were thousands
of players joining the game.
So I think that if you do the...
"the initial user experience is important,"
to have all of that...
those viralization mechanisms
you'll have people joining the game.
Juan: You Brazilians
are the most social people
in the whole world.
So becoming viral in Brazil
isn't a challenge.
I think the most important thing at the
"beginning is to build up the game,"
offer good content.
We...
since we have games with a lot of traffic
we do cross-promotion campaigns.
We all do the same thing.
"When we launch a new game,"
we advertise the games on current games.
That makes it so that the new game
grows quickly.
"And after the quality of the game,"
"the social features,"
"you Brazilians, social people,"
"that like to talk with your friends,"
"compete with your friends,"
only that way will your game grow.
"But the main part,"
"initially, we work with cross promotion."
>> Hi. My name is Paulo Camara.
"I work at CIT, too"
on the mobile network.
I want to explore the topic
that you talked about quickly
that's the situation of businesses
"using games,"
"for example, your games,"
as a way of reaching the consumer
[inaudible] the case of [Bees]
"uh, [Panner] is an obvious example,"
"but along the lines of [Bees], really, "
that used the dynamics of the game
to get a message
to reach the public.
Have you seen this grow?
Is this becoming more common?
Juan: Yes.
I'll talk first about my first time
which was with Colheita.
I'll explain the campaign a little.
We work with
digital agencies in Brazil.
We work with [Krafts] and
they wanted to reach the public.
and engage the public
in a different way.
"The game was very popular,"
is very popular.
So they wanted to begin communicating
with the public in a different way.
"But in.. with an ad, or with..."
"positioning the brand,"
but give the user an opportunity
"to interact with the brand,"
with the product
as part of the game.
I think that more than 5 million
people on the first day
grabbed MiniBees cement.
It was a very successful campaign.
viral [inaudible] over all channels.
So I think that the future
integration with brands
is more about the brand or
product interacting with the user
in a fun and different way.
We are working with
all digital agencies in Brazil.
Brands are starting to understand
the importance of
and the opportunity of being able to
interact with users in a different way.
So I think this is a
very interesting opportunity.
Eduardo: Let me offer that
there are two other examples
that are good for this.
One was the campaign
for the city of Belo Horizonte.
"Today, the whole app was conceived as a"
way to spread the word to prevent dengue
So the dynamics of the game were that
you do things to prevent dengue
"get rid of standing water, and such."
And this message was fun enough
to be an app in itself.
"In my opinion, it more strongly"
reinforces the union of the two things.
There's another app that I think
that they made really...
"they're not here, and that's [BaileyPolk]"
where the virtual good that [BaileyPolk] has.
So the association with the brand
is very strong.
A characterstic of the game
might be...
it's a combination of game and app.
"But I can buy a t-shirt, and whoever makes"
the t-shirt wants to put it on me.
The t-shirt can be for a soccer club
or for specific actions.
There was an action to imitate [inaudible] a
little before the premier of the movie.
"It went pretty well, too."
I think the union of virtual goods
can represent real goods a little.
Sold by a brand that has
a strong potential there.
>> My name is Eduardo.
I work with [Feelings] on games.
I wanted to produce things for Orkut.
I never saw a way to get different [inaudible]
because it has an API
that has access to
a very large database.
How is it that you began to find
these things for Orkut that I...
that we almost... never saw.
Eduardo: Sorry.
What are those things?
The developers?
The apps? or the API?
The resources?
>> The API itself.
There's a more...
more specialized database.
It gives a much bigger structure.
Eduardo: Cool.
Cool.
Let me answer that.
"First, we recognize that"
"social network markets, both from"
the perspective of apps as from
"the infrastructure, is very dynamic;"
it's growing very fast.
Today the main resources that we have are
the OpenSource apps or
the best way to get there is
from the menu at Orkut.
There's a link for developers.
There you can see the main
developer resources: API
"OpenSource, [inaudible] examples of apps"
[inaudible] tutorials.
Another part is what we
the Client Library
that's an API that you can call up
without being an app directly.
"So, for example, "
you can develop a...
a client that will access Orkut
"on a Java phone,"
or you can get your site
to send an activity to Orkut
or recover [inaudible] friends.
There's a whole lot of other new things
"we want to release soon,"
we understand that this is a market
where contact with developers
is what makes the social network
have more value.
So we really understand its value;
we want to move faster and faster.
>> Along the same lines I have
another question.
I think it was that developer who
"tried to work with Orkut,"
he hit on the question of the API.
Orkut's API is confusing
to work with.
I want to know if you have any
advance notice about the next release
and if you already have something
planned that you expect to facilitate.
so I can get into a community
to make an app
that I want my public to [inaudible]
like in that community.
I can do what I do on Facebook;
make a request and search for
those users who offer PayPal
or an app for them.
Eduardo: Great.
"Unfortunately, Google doesn't comment"
in any way before a release.
So it's our policy to avoid building up
expectations and then disappointing you.
The most I can say here
is the we understand that there's
still a long way to go
that we can work harder
than we're working.
And we'er providing resources
so that will happen.
So there's new things to come
I just can't make any specific promises.
Unfortunately. I understand that
you want a date.
This is the kind of thing
we can't answer directly.
What I can guarantee is that
we're working intensely
so that that will happen.
>> My name is [inaudible].
I'm [inaudible] developer...
... for [MultiConnect].
Here's my question:
Today there are lots of games like
World of Warcraft
that have specific items and that
there's a market outside of the game.
Does that outside market exist
"for MiniFazenda, too?"
Daniel: I think so.
I think... Well.
There's a lot of interest in
"that type of game, too."
But [Havidavi] like I said
MiniFazenda and that kind of farm
game to attract a lot of users
different types of users.
"For example, parents, children,"
the whole family plays this type of game.
"Warcraft, that type of game, is "
more niche.
There are a lot of users
"interested in playing,"
but I think theres a possibility for them
in the social gaming market.
But now you have to simplify
the game a little
"this kind of game, to get to the"
level of being a social good.
"And now, in the market we see"
more and more games like this.
"Civilizations, pared down for the "
"more social market,"
something simpler to...
users only want to play a few
"minutes, not hours, each day."
I think that in the future we'll see
more and more games like this.
I think that now in social gaming
we see the end of the era of...
OK... really big games.
"general ones, for everyone."
Now we have the opportunity for games
addressing more specific interests.
"For example, Poker, or for example,"
[Betspa] only for children. Yes.
I think that in this category
there's also the possibility for users
who play a lot of games like
Warcraft. That type.
Juan: I think that... games like
World of Warcraft
that kind of game is drawing
audiences with another architecture;
but those developers I'm seeing that
those developers are making
simpler games for social countries.
"So you'll be seeing that the games,"
the webgame are going to
social networks.
And there are also games
on social networks
"that won't only be on social networks,"
but will be outside of the bigger
social network.
So I think the two worlds
are starting to converge.
I think in the future there will be
a platform in which
games can work
in or out of social networks.
Eduardo: I just got a yellow card here.
So I think that this will have to be
our last question.
>> I'm Eduardo.
I'm the director of [Silks].
It's a game producer.
We basically work with
[adware] games.
I want to know if Google has any
"policy about brands, games,"
or games associated with brands
that affects [what happens with] Orkut.
Eduardo: Let me answer that directly.
We have some policies...
we are pretty specific:
nothing that is illegal in a country
where the game will operate.
"And each country, literally, "
has its own laws.
In some countries...
"guns might be prohibited,"
or hate speech;
there are lots of different laws.
and Google has to avoid all of that.
"But there's not much more than that,"
"the idea of the app,"
beyond some few things
like in... focused on...
"the [SonhaLuz] app, but without"
"user interaction,"
you can't sell the steps of an app
there are very few [interventions]
we make.
And they aren't all available in
the service agreement of the app.
but there are few things beyond
what I've said that are relevant
that you have to agree to.
Everyone.
I think that's all.
I want to thank everyone
for their participation.
I think it was really valuable.
I liked a lot of what I heard.
"I hope that you also enjoyed everything,"
and that you enjoy the rest of
the event. Thank you.
00:42:56.967,00:00:00.000